Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wo warst du? Warum bist du so spät?
Ich stand im Stau.
Intro Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 462 vom 9. Juli 2023.
Das ist heute. 9.
Juli? Nein, Juni. Juni.
Also.
Juno.
Sollte man Juno sagen? Juno?
Juno! Juli!
Hast du das mal gemacht? Juno sagen?
Juno und Juli. Ja?
Ja.
Boah, der sagt sowas. Muss man manchmal machen.
Am Telefon, wenn du sagst, Juni! Ja! Juli! Das ist wirklich bescheuert mit den beiden Monaten.
So ist das halt. Naja, naja, naja. Kommunikation, so schwierig, aber so wichtig auch.
Vor allem ist es wichtig im richtigen Monat zu sein.
Warum haben eigentlich die Österreicher da keine Lösung für?
Ich meine die sagen ja auch Jänner und so.
Also für so Monate wo man keine Probleme hat die auseinanderzuhalten,
da haben sie dann andere Worte. Aber wenn es dann mal wirklich um eine Lösung
geht, dann können die auch nicht liefern.
Haben sie wirklich keine?
Was kann Österreich eigentlich?
Österreich?
Das ist geil oder? Wir legen jetzt einfach die Schuld einfach so auf Österreich,
haben nichts mit der Diskussion zu tun. Einfach mal so ein kleiner Seitenhieb.
Leute das ist Politik. So macht man das.
Ablenken, die Schuld auf andere schieben.
Blame Canada.
Genau. Blame Canada. So sieht's aus.
Beziehungsweise Blame Austria.
Juni, Juni, Juli, Juli. Das steht hier im Internet. Was?
Das sind die Österreicher?
Die sagen, die haben uns nachgemacht. Ernsthaft? Ja. Das ist im Wiktionary Eintrag zu Jena.
Ach, aber das tun sie doch nicht wirklich. Oder sagt Thomas Juno?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich bleibe mal zurück, Blätter, keine Sorge, mal fragen.
Sagst du Junos?
Das muss jetzt geklärt werden, die wichtigen Dinge zuerst.
Halt, Stopp.
Naja.
Du warst shoppen Tim.
Achja mit den Worten ist das schwierig, seitdem du mir gesagt hast,
dass es Fittinge gibt, sehe ich überall nur noch Fittinge. Ne ich hab wirklich Fittinge gekauft.
Was für welche?
PVC Klebemuffen Fittinge heißt es da. Also es steht ja immer weiß er in so Amazon
Sucheinträgen steht ja dann immer
alles mögliche jedes denkbare Wort wie irgendjemand das nennen könnte.
Achso der mit der Google. Genau deswegen habe ich PVC Fitting Klebemuffe PVCU
Muffe Rohrverbinder Rohrschlauch Klebefitting zum Verkleben Qualität aus Europa gekauft.
Qualität aus Europa. Das wäre, falls das jemand googelt.
Na ja, wie viele?
Drei Assets. Jetzt fragst du dich, welches Rohr muss hier verlegt werden?
Das ist einfach für meine...
Für deine Fittingsammlung.
Meine Wellenfittinge. Ne, ist einfach, so ein PVC-Rohr ist leicht,
halbwegs stabil und mit PVC-Fitting-Klebemuffe,
Rohrverbinder, Rohrschlauchklebefitting zum Verkleben, Qualität aus Europa,
kann ich die halt dann in so kleine Segmente schneiden, die Rohre,
und dann einfach so ineinander stecken.
Und schon habe ich ein flexibles Mastsystem, was aber dann nicht so lang ist für den Transport.
Wenn man mal so eine Satellitenschüssel auf die richtige Höhe bringen will,
dann mache ich einfach so ein Fitting drauf. Ich klebe Mofe PVC-TU,
Mofe Rohrverbinder, Rohrschlauch.
Aber das ist ja dann ein fetter Fitting, ne?
Fünf Zentimeter.
Fünf Zentimeter Fitting?
Für so ein dickes Rohr halt.
Aber dann stecke ich das halt ein bisschen so wie Lego und dann nehme ich halt
immer so ein Rohrsegment, sagen wir mal so einen Meter und dann mache ich da
oben so ein PVC-Fitting, Klebemuffe, PVC-U-Muffe, Rohrverbinder,
Rohrschlauch, Klebefitting zum Verkleben.
Wir haben die T-Head aus Europa drauf und dann kann ich schon das nächste Rohr wieder reinstecken.
Und wie machst du das unten fest?
Ich vergräbe es einfach in den Boden, einfach kurz. Also einfach drauf stellen.
Ich mach das ja dann eh irgendwas fest mit nem Strap und dann passt das schon.
Das muss jetzt nicht Sturmreif sein, aber es ist halt die Alternative zu so ner Teleskopstange.
So, die ja dann auch so.
Ja, die ich habe.
Genau, du hast ja sowas. Aber ich dachte mir, wenn schon Fittinge,
dann richtig. Und dann habe ich halt zugeschlagen.
PVC-Fitting, Klebemuffe, PVC-U-Muffe, Rohrverbinder, Rohrschlauch,
Klebefitting zum Verkleben, Qualität aus Europa. So sieht es nämlich aus.
Das ist schon natürlich am Campingplatz, einfach mal, da wird halt gezeigt.
Da zeigt man sich auch als stolzer Europäer. Ja.
Mit seinen Fittingen. Drei Fittinge macht der Tim, hat er ein Mast, ja super.
Ja gucken wir mal, ob die Politik auch mithalten kann mit der Qualität aus Europa.
Oh ja, ich meine Klebefitting ist ja auch so, warum bist du so spät gekommen?
Was hast du so ein Klebefitting? Klebefittinge. Was dem einen seit Wellensittig
ist, dem anderen seit Klebefitting.
Die Klebefittinger, die sind ja, also ich war, obwohl das können wir gleich
auch bei, können eigentlich erstmal direkt über letzte Generation Feedback sprechen.
Ähm, oh, achso nee, ich wollte gar keinen spezifischen Kommentar,
es gab nämlich genug, es gab genügend Kommentare zur letzten Generation und
den schwerwiegenden Fällen von Nötigung, die die begehen.
Dazu zwei Dinge, vielleicht sind wir nicht ausreichend darauf eingegangen,
was es bedeutet, wenn ein Strafvermittlungsverfahren nach Paragraf 129 läuft,
weil das bedeutet, dass du dann eben auch den vollen Katalog der Strafprozessordnung
als in dem Ermittlungsverfahren nutzen darfst.
Also Leute observieren, Telefone abhören, Wohnungen durchsuchen und so weiter, ne?
Und ich denke, dass das auch vor allem der Grund ist, dass sie dieses Ermittlungsverfahren
anstrengen, damit sie diese Maßnahmen ergreifen können.
Und da gab es ja sehr viele Leute, die sich schwerwiegend eingeschränkt fühlten,
dadurch, dass da ein paar Leute mal für den Stau sorgen.
Wir hatten ja glaube ich auch klar gemacht, dass wir beide nicht unbedingt der Meinung sind,
dass das jetzt der zielführendste aller Proteste ist,
weil er eben den Nachteil hat, dass er genau das herbeiführt,
nämlich sehr viele unglückliche Leute in der Mitte der Gesellschaft.
Gleichzeitig habe ich ja den unsouveränen Umgang einiger männlicher Zeitgenossen
mit diesen Leuten aufgezeigt.
Da fühlten sich einige angesprochen.
Sie sagten, es wären nicht nur Kartoffeln, die das machen.
Es gäbe auch Mitbürger aus Europa und Eurasien, die ebenfalls mit Gewalt auf
die letzte Generation reagiert hätten.
Das ist keine Entschuldigung, meine lieben Freunde. Außerdem,
Kartoffel ist eine Lebenseinstellung.
Das hat nichts mit Nationalität zu tun.
Und das ist a way of life. Potato is a way of life, ja.
Okay, naja gut, da mag es schon sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzungen geben,
wann dieses Wort benutzt wird, weil ich glaube Kartoffel ist dann doch eher so generisch deutsch.
Okay, gut. Dann habe ich das anders gemeint, ich bleibe dabei und darauf wollte
ich auch nochmal kurz eingehen. Ich war am Sonntag, also letzten Sonntag,
war in Berlin die Sternfahrt. Kennst du Sternfahrt? Ja.
ADFC-Sternfahrt, da fahren die von überall, also von unterschiedlichen Regionen Brandenburgs.
Nach Berlin zum großen Stern und auf diesem Wege fahren sie auch eine signifikante
Strecke über die Berliner Stadtautobahn.
Und das ist ja so geil. Also du fährst einfach mit deinem Fahrrad so sonntags
schön auf die Autobahn drauf und fährst dann so.
Da bist du mitgefahren.
Ja klar. Super. Wahnsinn. Es ist einfach toll. Also es ist wirklich einfach
geil mit dem Fahrrad über die Autobahn zu fahren.
Du hast Platz, halbwegs ordentlichen Asphalt, einfach spitze, schöne Sicht und so.
Wunderbare Einrichtung so eine Autobahn, wenn man sie für fahrräderfrei gibt.
Wenn man keine Autos drauf hat.
Fahrradbahn. Super.
Und dann hatte ich das Glück am Montag, bin ich morgens losgefahren zur Arbeit
und dann dachte ich auch,
oh hier ist aber ein ungewöhnlicher Stau an der Ampel, da hatte die letzte Generation
sich wieder festgeklebt und dann konnte ich mit meinem Fahrrad an diesen Autoschlangen
vorbei, hab dann noch freundlich die Festgeklebten gegrüßt, die konnten halt
nur zurücknicken, konnten nicht winken.
Und dann hatte ich die Frankfurter Allee für mich selber. Das war auch gut.
Dann konnte ich die Frankfurter Allee drei Spuren jede Richtung leer und auf
der anderen Seite konnte ich halt die ganzen stehenden Autofahrer sehen.
Und das ist ja insgesamt sowieso, deswegen kenn ich jetzt auch diese aggressiven Reaktionen,
die nämlich bei so Critical Mass, also bei Großfahrraddemonstrationen,
regelmäßig die Autofahrer ja auch in die Fahrradfahrer reinbrettern.
Hintergrund ist, also die fahren in die Fahrradmengen rein, versuchen Menschen
zu überfahren. Ja klar, ist auch mir schon mehrmals passiert.
Also du hast, der Zusammenhang so einer Critical Mass ist ja,
du schließt dich ja quasi zu einem Konvoi zusammen und dann bist du,
das gilt übrigens für alles mögliche, ich kenne jetzt nicht genau die StVO-Regel
da, aber in dem Moment wo du ein langer Fahrzeugverbund bist,
ist glaube ich der Begriff.
Fahren als geschlossener Verband.
Ja genau.
Paragraf 27 StVO.
Oder ist der zu lang? Wahrscheinlich ist der zu lang.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich hier den Originaltext bekomme.
Ich hab hier gerade nur so eine FAQ.
Also dadurch, dass du der geschlossene...
Hierbei handelt es sich um mehrere am Verkehr teilnehmende Fahrzeuge oder Personen,
die sich gemeinsam in einem Verband miteinander fortbewegen,
also dicht beieinander fahren, um die Verbindung zueinander nicht zu verlieren.
Ja, ein geschlossener Verband besteht damit nicht nur zwingend aus vielen Autos,
sondern kann genauso von Fußgängern bzw.
Radfahrern gebildet werden. Das Merkmal geschlossen erfüllen sie,
wenn Außenstehende unmittelbar erkennen können, dass sie zueinander gehören.
Und die Konsequenz daraus ist, nach meinem Verständnis, der Verband kommt. Die Ampel ist grün.
Der Verband fährt in den Kreuzungsbereich. Die Ampel schaltet auf rot,
dann bleibt der Verband zusammen.
Und um das eben auch zu erleichtern, fährt die Polizei üblicherweise diesen
Demonstrationen voraus,
sperrt die Kreuzung, bis der Verband dann in die Kreuzung reinfährt und dann
fahren die zur nächsten Kreuzung, sperren die wieder ab, lasst den Verband da durchfahren.
So jetzt passiert es allerdings, dass ab und zu mal Leute Löcher reißen in diesem
Verband, wo es dann ein bisschen aufgeht.
Das passiert einmal dadurch, dass manche Leute vielleicht einfach mal langsam
fahren, ist ne Steigung oder so.
Das passiert aber auch regelmäßig, weil Autofahrer dann einfach da rein brettern
und nicht warten wollen.
Und aus dem Grunde machst du üblicherweise in dem Moment, wo die Polizei weg
ist, fahren andere aus dem Verband und stellen sich mit ihren Fahrrädern vor die Autos.
Damit die nicht auf die Idee kommen loszufahren.
Teilweise kommen die genau deswegen dann auf die Idee und fahren dann halt die
Fahrradfahrer, die vor ihnen stehen, an.
Und tu mir leid, kein Verständnis für. Habe ich kein Verständnis für.
Es ist halt so ein Privilegiendenken,
was aus so einer asymmetrischen Kräfteverhältnisse,
also ich denke, dass viele Leute halt schon aus der Tatsache,
dass sie jetzt von so viel Metall und Zeug umgeben sind groß,
schwer, Ja, dann auch so eine Art Privileg ableiten, das war zumindest lange
Zeit so, das bröckelt jetzt so langsam.
Das Selbstverständnis, dass das Auto in irgendeiner Form jetzt so das Primat
hat und wenn man mit dem Auto unterwegs ist,
hat jetzt erstmal alles andere zu weichen, anstatt sich einer Denke anzuschließen
mit Leute zu berücksichtigen, die sozusagen am schwächsten sind in dem Moment.
Ich glaube da kommt noch ein anderer Faktor rein und zwar, ich mein,
wenn du mal wirklich in Berlin jetzt beispielsweise, wenn du da mal Auto fährst,
du wirst ja unmittelbar bescheuert, das erträgt ja kein Mensch.
Du wirst ja sofort aggressiv.
Überall Stau, alle acht Meter ne Ampel, hier Spurwechsel und so weiter.
Die anderen alle aggressiv, schneiden dich und so weiter und ich find das völlig
verständlich sogar, dass man.
Wenn man jetzt zu Stoßzeiten in Berlin mit einem Auto fährt,
gerade irgendwie morgens zur Arbeit, also ich mein,
wenn man die bescheuerte Entscheidung trifft, morgens um neun Uhr durch Berlin
Mitte mit dem Auto zu fahren,
da muss man entweder vorher irgendwie sich echt einen guten Brüggungstee kochen,
aber man darf auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie sagen man hat einen Termin oder
so, du wirst halt wirklich aggressiv dabei, das ist eine frustrierende Erfahrung.
Und das wundert mich auch nicht, dass die Leute dabei aggressiv werden.
Was ich aber sehr spannend fand, ist, wie Leute das Herbeiführen eines Staus
als so einen schwerwiegenden Eingriff in den Verkehr und ihre persönliche Freiheit nehmen.
Weil, ich hab mal geschaut, 2019, also das war prä-Corona, verbrachen Autofahrerinnen
und Fahrer durchschnittlich 46 Stunden im Stau. Das ist nur der Durchschnitt.
Das wird jetzt einige geben, die dann einen sehr viel größeren Peak haben und ich würde schätzen,
diejenigen, die in Berlin wohnen und meinen sie müssten morgens mit dem Auto
zur Arbeit fahren, in Berlin Mitte, da könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass die die Zahl auch ein bisschen reißen, so.
Aber 46 Stunden im Stau, das musst du mal auf dein Jahreskontingent rechnen.
Im Prinzip also eine Stunde Stau pro Woche im Jahr oder natürlich auch in zwei
Jahren, bleibt ja gleich.
Und wenn du jetzt mal eine halbe Stunde stehlen musst, scheint mir das nicht
so ein schwerer Eingriff in dein Leben zu sein.
Die Reaktion klar, aber natürlich ist das ärgerlich, ganz klar.
Aber es erlaubt dir nicht irgendwie mit Gewalt zu reagieren.
Na gut, also das stelle ich komplett außer Frage.
Und ganz kurz, ein Punkt der mir noch einfällt, der sehr wichtig ist in diesem
Kontext, an der Dorfstreiße sehe ich die selten kleben, die gehen ja spezifisch
an große Verkehrsknotenpunkte in Großstädten, wo ohnehin Stau ist.
Also wenn die jetzt irgendwie die Dorfstraße verkleben und du kommst aus Brandenburg
nicht in ein anderes Dorf in Brandenburg oder so. Die ganzen Leute,
die davon betonen, dass sie auf Autos angewiesen sind.
Menschen die, was weiß ich, ein bisschen außerhalb der Stadt wohnen oder sowas,
die sind ja in der Regel nicht betroffen. Also die, die wirklich von sich behaupten
können, dass sie ein KFZ brauchen, die sehe ich da selten.
Ehrlich gesagt sehe ich da meistens Leute, wo ich mir noch nicht mal sicher
bin, ob die irgendwo hinfahren oder vielleicht doch nur rum.
Also dünnes Eis, weil ich meine, was nun im Einzelnen immer die Gründe sind
und viele Leute sind halt auch einfach im Business unterwegs und keine Ahnung
und dann sitzt du da in deinem Auto und du bist irgendwie Betreuerin von irgendwelchen
älteren Menschen und musst wirklich von Person zu Person mit dem Auto reisen,
weil das ist halt einfach the way, weil du irgendwie Zeug dabei hast und so was.
Mühelos komme ich auf verschiedenste Szenarien, wo man sagen kann,
kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen, aber ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht weiter
vertiefen, deine Position ist ja an der Stelle auch ganz klar.
Um mal wieder auf die letzte Generation zurückzukommen und das,
was sie eigentlich bewirken wollen, ist ja...
Ich sag mal, so eine Art aufrütteln, das ist ja das eigentlich was sie ja quasi wollen.
Sie wollen die Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form irgendwo hinbewegen.
Das ist ja ihr Ziel, ihr erklärtes Ziel. Die Gesellschaft soll sich ändern,
die Gesellschaft soll motiviert werden, etwas anderes zu tun,
als sie es derzeit macht.
Und ich glaube, dass diese Straßenkleberaktion, was das Erreichen dieser Ziele
betrifft, eine Vollkatastrophe gewesen ist. Weil man hat sich nur Ärger eingehandelt.
Ich merke das auch daran, wie Kinder, die das so reflektieren, die sagen Klimakleber.
Das ist das einzige Wort, was hängt.
Das ist von Bild geprägt, aber ja.
Egal, aber es ist da so, ja, ah ja die Klimaklima,
da ist sozusagen überhaupt gar keine positive Konnotation drin,
weil das ja irgendwie auch langsam ein bisschen albern klingt und vor allem
ist es alles immer nur geprägt aus dieser Auseinandersetzung mit,
ich sag mal, normalen Leuten, ja?
Und dieses permanente Unverständnis auf beiden Seiten,
warum macht ihr das oder warum versteht ihr meine Gründe gerade nicht,
warum ich mich jetzt aufrege und da kann man ja tausend Szenarien nennen,
wie du das jetzt gerade getan hast, warum das vielleicht unangemessen ist, sich aufzuregen,
aber genauso würden mir jetzt tausend Szenarien einfallen, wo das sehr wohl
angemessen ist oder nachvollziehbar ist, sagen wir es mal, ob es angemessen
ist, lasse ich mal außen vor, aber wo es zumindest nachvollziehbar ist.
Und es richtet sich an Leute meistens.
Die üblicherweise in dieser Gesellschaft, abgesehen davon, dass sie alle paar Jahre mal einen Stimmzettel ausfüllen, relativ wenig Einfluss auf dieses Geschehen tatsächlich wirklich haben.
Insofern finde ich das jetzt interessant und in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar und vielleicht auch richtig, dass sie ja jetzt angekündigt haben, ihre Strategie auch dahingehend zu ändern.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht klug sich die.
Also mit so vielen Leuten, die da engagiert sind, finde ich, ist der Output relativ dünne.
Also da kann man dann doch mehr erreichen.
Weil es sehr viel Ärger erzeugt. Jetzt muss man erstmal sein Image wieder gerade biegen und ein Image gerade biegen in der Öffentlichkeit gehört zu den schwierigsten Dingen überhaupt.
Das stimmt.
Anyway, ich glaube das haben wir jetzt auch immer ausgezeichnet.
Aber ich klebe mich jetzt hier fest.
Genau, alles klar. Dann checken wir noch mal kurz deine Generationszugehörigkeit.
Wir haben einen Kommentar bekommen von Jan. Jan schreibt, Tim gehört zur Generation
X und Linus zu den Millennials Generation Y.
Why?
Ja, why? Ja, warum? Ihr seid aber beide nur drei Jahre von den jeweiligen Altersgrenzen
der Generation entfernt. Wenn Tim also drei Jahre älter wäre, wäre er ein Babyboomer.
Wenn Linus drei Jahre älter wäre, wäre er ein Gen Xer. Ihr könnt euch also aussuchen,
was ihr seid. Tim ein junger Babyboomer oder ein alter Gen Xer oder Linus ein
junger Gen Xer oder ein alter Millennial. Was, was, lieber?
Ich wüsste, ich kenne nur die Vorurteile über Gen Z, deswegen ich muss mich
jetzt erst beschäftigen mit, will man lieber Gen Xer oder Millennial sein?
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Also ich weiß, ich will definitiv nicht in die Baby Boomer Kategorie.
Okay Boomer.
Von daher bin ich lieber ein alter Xer. Alter Xer. Alter Xer.
Generation X war auch die einzige Generation, wo es cool klang.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Und Millenial muss ich sagen hat so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht,
Millenial, wie stehst du so zum neuen Jahrtausend?
Bist du mehr mit dem einen Fuß im alten oder mehr im neuen?
Ich bin relativ klar Gen Y, das würde ich erstmal festhalten.
Gen Y am Arbeitsplatz.
Okay, also Millennial. Du bist ein alter Millennial, weil es ist ja das gleiche am Arbeitsplatz.
In der Politik. Laut Camilla Kors wird der Generation Y nachgesagt,
ihre Angehörigen seien eher linksorientiert, da in Deutschland linke Positionen
Mainstream seien. Dies müsse man jedoch differenzieren.
Wo ist denn überhaupt eine linke Position Mainstream?
Das ist, also genau, das ist, wenn ich mir das angucke,
das sind dann so diese, wer ist Camilla Kostas, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine
Geisteswissenschaftlerin, die dann da irgendwie, ne süddeutsche Zeit,
Ressortleiterin Politik, na gut, okay.
Politik, Wirtschaft, Gesellschaft. Ich weiß nicht was, also es ist natürlich
auch schon hart über so eine gesamte Generation zu urteilen.
Deswegen fand ich es übrigens interessant, dass keiner, kein Kommentar schien
sich auf die Gen Z Witze zu beziehen, die ich ja so lustig fand.
Da hab ich eigentlich gedacht, da würden wir Ärger bekommen.
Wann geht denn das los hier mit Generation Z?
Ich wollte jetzt erst mal Gen Y, aber das ist mir irgendwie...
Also Z ist ab Geburtsjahr 97.
Oh, die Zoomers.
Also die, die jetzt alle Zoom benutzen.
Und jetzt kommt Generation Alpha.
Achso, weil man jetzt bei Z angekommen ist, muss man jetzt wieder vorne anfangen,
das heißt bis mit 20s, das heißt wenn du jetzt sozusagen geboren bist,
demnächst mit 20, zwei, drei Jahren, dann bekommst du eine Generation Beta.
Bist du sozusagen eine Beta-Version.
Das wird noch lustig.
Oh man ey, auf die hab ich ja Bock. Also Gen Y, also irgendwie stehen mir hier
zu, hier sind mir zu differenzierte Vorurteile.
Nächste ist, wer Deutschland, achso, die Generation Y sei nicht unpolitisch.
Das ist schon wieder so, nicht unpolitisch. Sie definieren Politik allerdings
anders als bisher gewohnt.
Viele früher als politisch definierte Themen seien für Ypsiloner heute eher
eine Frage von Konsumethik und Lebensstil.
Du bist jetzt bei welcher Generation?
Y.
Ah, bei dir.
Sie wollen nach ihren eigenen Vorstellungen legen und binden sich nicht an politische
Organisationen. Regelmäßige Mitarbeitung und Unterstützung sei für die meisten
Ypsiloner nicht erstrebenswert.
Also irgendwie weiß ich nicht. Bildung, Hauptsache Abitur.
Was man dabei wirklich lernt ist, spielt innerlich keine Rolle,
was zählt ist das gute Zeugnis.
Das wäre nahezu zynisch. Umgang mit Krisen.
Das Leben in Unsicherheit empfinden sie, empfänden sie aus diesem Grund als völlig normal.
Ja das ist alles Quatsch.
Da guckt mal hier, Generation X wurde prophezeit, dass sie sich erst mal ohne
Kriegseinwirkung mit weniger Wohlstand und ökonomischer Sicherheit begnügen
müssen als die Elterngeneration.
Aber andererseits für deren ökonomische und ökologischen Sünden büße.
Ha! Siehste? Ich muss nämlich dafür büßen, dass meine Eltern so scheiße waren. So sieht's nämlich aus.
So und da könnte man jetzt auch einfach mal ein bisschen mehr Verständnis zeigen,
was ich für ein armes Leben führen muss, wir alten Gen Xer.
Stattdessen kann ich nicht mit meinem SUV hier durch Berlin brettern,
wie es mir passt. Das ist doch alles nur Kompensation.
Das ist diese Schuld, die ich auf mir habe, um das von den Schultern zu bekommen.
Ja, also wir bitten um ein bisschen mehr Rücksicht auf unsere Generation.
Bitte macht uns die Kreuzung frei.
So, mal gucken, jetzt fangen die noch an meinen Privatjet zu blockieren.
Hört doch mal auf. Frechheit.
So dann haben wir Böhmermann kritisiert und dazu kommentiert,
und zwar spezifisch die Fäser Schönbum Geschichte.
Dazu kommentiert Henrik, die Schönbohm-Sendung von Böhmermann sehe ich gar nicht so negativ.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Ausstrahlung wollte das ZDF-Magazin-Royalteam wohl ihren Zustauern
einfach mal zeigen, wie unqualifiziert der Leiter des BSI ist.
Klar, da wurde dann eine große Schau draus gemacht und nahezu alles war bereits
bekannt, nur hatte das Thema wohl nicht die Aufmerksamkeit erhalten,
die das Team für angebracht hielt.
So gesehen ist die Tatsache, dass Schönbum sich eine Erlaubnis von oben geholt
hat, um auf das Jubiläum zu gehen, auch eher eine Randnotiz,
weil es ja nichts an seiner Unqualifiziertheit ändert.
Dass Fäser auf die Sendung reagierte, wie sie reagierte, war dann doch nicht Böhmermanns Schuld.
Ihr habt ja auch korrekterweise erwähnt, dass Fäser dabei nicht gut ausgesehen hat.
Anstatt, dass Faeser auf die Regierung verweist, die Schönbrunn ernannt hatte,
zu erläutern, warum der BSI-Chefposten nicht einfach ausgetauscht werden kann,
und anstatt einzugestehen, dass die Erlaubnis zu Besuch des Jubiläums ein Fehler
war, verfiel sie offenbar in eine Art Panikmodus.
Vielmehr sehe ich die Fehler, die im Zusammenhang mit der Sendung passiert sind,
bei Faeser können und nicht bei Böhmermann. bei Böhmermann.
Daher halte ich es auch für unangebracht, hier vom Ruin einer Karriere durch Böhmermann zu reden.
Was den Fall Hessenthaler angeht, bin ich komplett bei euch.
Da muss sich Böhmermann wirklich unheimlich verrannt haben und seine anwaltlichen
Reaktionen finde ich dreist und vollkommen unangebracht.
Ja, Henrik, hast du einen sehr wichtigen Punkt. Klar, also abgesetzt wurde der
Schönbumm von Frau Felser und ich hätte es nicht besser zusammenfassen können,
als du das hier gemacht hast.
Ich glaube es gab schon diese ist Schönbrunn noch im Amt Webseite von Böhmermann,
aber okay, das ist auch ein altes Meme.
Ja, also da kamen dann halt zwei Dinge zusammen. Ich dachte auch,
dass wir das relativ klar getrennt haben, aber vielleicht ist es ja gut, dass es so ist.
Ja, wir haben uns schon ein bisschen mehr über Böhmermann beklagt und insofern ein wichtiger Punkt.
Du steigerst dich da ja auch mal rein.
Das gehört jetzt zum Sendungskonzept. Du weißt gar nicht, was für ein ausgeglichener
Typ ich bin. Ich muss mich ja immer künstlich echauffieren.
Ich trinke vorher drei Tassen Kaffee. Klar.
Ein weiterer Kommentar auch von Henrik. Ist das der selbe Henrik?
Könnte der sein. Glaube ja. Dann auch nochmal zu Böhmermann.
Hier geht es dann allerdings um unseren Vergleich mit John Oliver.
Er schreibt zu Böhmermann und Last Week Tonight, finde es lustig,
dass ihr die Brücke zwischen diesen beiden Sendungen schlagt,
da John Oliver in der Vergangenheit ein ähnliches Argument vorbrachte.
Der hat nämlich vor vier Jahren noch sehr oft gesagt, dass man seine Show nicht
so ernst nehmen dürfe und keine journalistischen Standards anlegen darf.
Er sei eben nur ein Comedian. Dabei ging es zu John Olivers Verteidigung aber
nie um Quellenschutz, sondern den Wahrheitsgehalt seiner Sendung.
Ja man nennt das den John Oliver Effekt im übrigen.
Ist der bekannt? War mir nicht bekannt.
Nee der John Oliver, also nicht seine Reaktion da drauf,
sondern der John Oliver Effekt ist, man könnte dann halt jetzt auch von einem
Böhmermann Effekt reden,
dass in dem Moment wo John Oliver diese Themen aufgreift, es dann dazu führt,
dass dann auch der gesamte mediale Zirkus dieses Thema aufnimmt.
Also wenn der irgendwas thematisiert, dann ist das sozusagen dadurch,
durch die Popularität seiner Sendung in the News und du weißt ja wie das ist
mit dem Newscycle, wenn etwas in the News ist, die alle anderen reden darüber,
dann müssen wir auch darüber reden, weil sonst sind wir ja sozusagen hinterher.
Das ist auch glaube ich etwas, was man so nicht verhindern kann,
das liegt so ein bisschen in der Natur der Sache.
Faszinierender Effekt bei vielerlei, sowohl bei Themen, die passieren,
als auch bei Themen, die nicht passieren, ne?
Genau, in beide Richtungen. Und ich würde sagen, das ist auch sicherlich etwas,
was uns auch manchmal so geht. Also wenn jetzt alle über irgendein Thema reden,
dann fühlen wir uns auch...
Kleber Kleber. Und ist auch jetzt nicht unbedingt falsch,
weil es ja dann auch ein Bedürfnis gibt sicherlich bei vielen,
auch mehrere Betrachtungssichtweisen und idealerweise der Sache dann auch zu
erhalten, also sich explizit auch zu einem Medium des Vertrauens,
also zum Beispiel diesem, Zuzuwenden dem Denkmal.
Oder so, ja, okay gut, meinetwegen, vielleicht ist das ja auch eine große Scheiße,
aber erstmal gucken was Linus dazu zu sagen.
Ja, also erstmal erklären. Und vor allen Dingen sich dem Thema nähern, bevor wir zu Ende sind.
Ich hab mir die verlinkten Interviews mal angeschaut und es ist richtig,
also John Oliver verzieht dann schnell mal so das Gesicht, wenn er in diese
Journalismusgeschichte gezogen wird.
Also John Oliver steht ja sehr in dieser Tradition der Daily Show.
Du kennst das ja auch. Und ich war ganz froh muss ich sagen,
dass ich das damals so mitbekommen habe, noch als das so richtig losging.
Im Hintergrund, wer das nicht kennt, The Daily Show ist ein Format von Comedy
Central, das gab es schon so ein paar Jahre, das dümpelte so ein wenig vor sich
hin, bis es dann von Jon Stewart übernommen wurde.
Und Jon Stewart hat dieser Sendung in den USA ein Leben eingehaucht,
dadurch dass er, und im Prinzip kann man sagen, das ist so ein bisschen der
Ursprung dieses journalistisch angehauchten Comedy Formats, das ist sozusagen der Urknall gewesen.
Dass Jon Stewart halt wirklich harte politische Themen aufgegriffen hat,
die aktuell waren, was auch immer es ist, sozusagen.
Und in seiner Comedy News Show das sozusagen berichtet hat, und wie man das
heute so kennt, auf der einen Seite berichtet man, was wirklich passiert ist,
und im nächsten Satz macht man irgendwie einen Joke dazu. Und dadurch...
Auch harte News auf einmal konsumierbar gemacht hat.
Konsumierbar und unterhaltsam.
Dadurch, dass es unterhaltsam ist, überhaupt erst konsumierbar gemacht hat,
weil es ja auch immer schwierig ist, geht mir ja zum Beispiel auch so,
ich verfolge jetzt irgendwie die ganze Zeit immer so Krieg in der Ukraine,
gucke ich jeden Tag irgendwie eine halbe Stunde Content mindestens.
Und wenn dann halt wieder so Rückschläge passieren, wie jetzt mit diesem Staudamm
und so weiter, dann ist das halt auch immer so, oh fuck, gar keinen Bock auf
schlechte Nachrichten und so und man muss irgendwie auch so ein Coping-Mechanismus
haben. Und da hat Daily Show wirklich Wunder gewirkt.
Perfektes Beispiel, ich hab neulich mal geschaut, leider ist die glaube ich
nicht so ohne weiteres online zu finden, aber falls ihr die Möglichkeit habt
das nochmal irgendwo aufzuspüren, vielleicht findet ja jemand einen Link.
Damals als dieser Katrina Sturm über New Orleans rüber ging,
da gab's tatsächlich gerade Sendepause bei Daily Show, die erste Sendung quasi
ein paar Tage nachdem das Desaster sich da entwickelt hat.
Die Sendung über Katrina von Daily Show total episch,
also das war einfach die Art und Weise, wie man mit so einem totalen Desaster
und Zusammenbruch eigentlich so der Gesellschaft in den USA,
die es ja letztlich war durch die unterlassene Hilfeleistung dort,
wie man damit umgegangen ist und wie die in dieser Sendung umgegangen sind und
wie die einfach über den Humor das noch konsumierbar gemacht haben,
das war wirklich wegweisend.
Dann stieg halt der Stern von Daily Show auch sehr schnell auf und John Oliver und viele andere,
die heutzutage ganz große, Steven Colbert und eine ganze Reihe von weiteren,
waren ja dann alle in dieser Show die sogenannten Korrespondenten.
Dieses Prinzip, was du ja auch bei der Heute Show hast.
Ja gut, aber heute Show ist einfach... Ich wollte gerade sagen,
natürlich ist die Daily Show das Vorbild für die Heute Show,
aber die Heute Show ist einfach sowas von stumpf.
Das ist... man darf diese beiden nicht in einem Satz ver...
Ich hab auch schon gelacht bei der Heute Show, muss ich sagen.
Wann war das denn? Bei der Werbung?
Ich bin auch ein großer, boah ne das ist so eine Verstumpfung,
das ist nicht mein Punkt, mein Punkt ist nur der,
da kommt das alles her und John Oliver ist einer von mehreren,
auch Stephen Colbert macht das ja in seiner Late Show auch grandios,
Er ist mit dem Colbert Report,
jetzt hat er ja die große Late Show seit Jahren übernommen und macht das ja genauso,
also mit seinem Monolog immer an dieser Sendung, das ist einfach eine Reflexion
des Wahnsinns und ich glaube,
dass er große Verdienste hat an der amerikanischen Bevölkerung,
die durch diese Trump-Zeit begleitet zu haben, die das vielleicht gar nicht
überlebt hätten ohne ihn, nicht zu ertragen.
Muss man noch ganz kurz auch sagen, dass die Daily Show ja dann auch inzwischen
schon vor vielen Jahren von Trevor Noah übernommen wurde und damit auch nochmal
echt, also der Typ ist auch erstaunlich gut.
In letzter Zeit gibt's irgendwie so ne, ich weiß nicht ob der gerade Urlaub
macht oder so, aber der holt ja jetzt immer mehr aus seinem Team.
Nein, nein, der Stefanova hat aufgehört und sie haben noch keinen offiziellen
Nachfolger festgelegt,
der hat im November oder so gesagt, das war's und sie haben jetzt noch keinen
offiziellen Nachfolger gefunden und deswegen fahren sie gerade das Konzept,
dass sie immer die Daily Show irgendjemandem für eine Woche geben,
ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt mehr so eine Art Casting ist oder mehr eine,
wir wissen noch nicht so richtig, weil wir haben uns vorher keine Gedanken gemacht,
wir dachten der macht noch länger und so.
Das ist so der Effekt, also.
Ach scheiße, das wusste ich nicht, das finde ich richtig traurig.
Da sind ja auch viele in der zweiten Reihe, also ich bin mir relativ sicher,
die werden schon nachvergabt.
Sorry, das ist, ja, ne, also ich, keine Frage. Nein, der ist spitze,
ich muss auch Autobiografie von Trevor Noah lesen, ein wunderbares,
sollte man gelesen haben, der gibt's aber als Hörbuch.
Ja, toller Typ aus Südafrika, der in den USA kam und so.
Wollen wir eigentlich noch über Netzpolitik reden?
Nee, aber ich finde das auch einen wichtigen Punkt, weil um vielleicht mal zum
Kernargument dieses Kommentars zurückzukommen und diesem Verhältnis,
okay, was ist denn jetzt sozusagen Journalismus? Und ich glaube,
das ist generell eine Gummibezeichnung.
Also das ist einfach, da hat so jeder seinen eigenen Ansatz und ehrlich gesagt,
ich hab mir diese Frage ja auch schon gestellt.
Nicht, dass ich mich jetzt als Comedy-Vertreter verstehe, aber diese Frage,
wie viel Journalismus ist jetzt zum Beispiel in meinen Podcast-Formaten?
In diesem vielleicht mehr, in gewisser Hinsicht, aber...
Ich arbeite nicht journalistisch, in dem eigentlichen Sinne.
Auch ich sehe das Podcasting primär über den Aspekt der Unterhaltung,
aber eben genau mit so einem ähnlichen Spin vielleicht, sodass ich denke so
unterhaltsam über die Themen zu reden,
die uns alle bewegen, ist auch eine Methode sich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
Ohne dass man das gleich unter dieser Kategorie Journalismus abheften muss,
die so eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit immer in den Raum trägt und dann auch sagt
so, hier gibt es die Standards, die musst du erfüllen und so weiter,
sonst ist es nicht richtig und dann ist es nicht wahr und so weiter und ich
denke, es gibt halt auch noch andere Darreichungsformen.
Deswegen kann ich sowohl Böhmermanns als auch John-Olivers Ansatz verstehen
zu sagen, nee, das ist jetzt nicht das wo ich herkomme. Wir beschäftigen uns
zwar mit denselben Themen, aber deswegen ist es nicht zwangsläufig in der Kategorie
Journalismus. 100 Prozent.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es einen verantwortungslosen Umgang mit der Reichweite genehmigt.
Natürlich. Und vielleicht ist auch genau das,
das Problem, das wir gerade haben, dass früher man davon ausging,
ok entweder etwas ist Journalismus, weil es in irgendeiner Form Sach- oder Faktenberichterstattung
ist, Dokumentation, Nachrichten, sonst was.
Also das ist, vielleicht ist das insgesamt ein bisschen unterreguliert,
aber unterverstanden das Thema.
Ja also da bin ich auch ganz bei dir, Verantwortung für in unserem Fall halt
Hörerschaft muss man übernehmen,
also aus Sichtbarkeit und aus so einer Rolle dieser Asymmetrie,
die wir ja zwangsläufig haben, entsteht meiner Auffassung nach auch automatisch.
Verantwortung und der muss man halt irgendwie gerecht werden.
Auf nen nässenden Wund, das könnte dann wehtun und ohne dann kann ich dann auch nix dafür.
Alright, sollen wir mal zu den Themen kommen?
Ja okay, meinst du?
Immer das gleiche.
Die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung wird fünf Jahre alt.
Ich hätte fast gedacht, dass die älter ist.
Fünf Jahre nur? Ja. Ist das so lange her, dass wir unsere, welche Sendung?
200, 300, die kommt total durcheinander. Stimmt, da hatten wir den JPA bei uns. Ja, ja.
Wir waren ja hier. Was war das?
400? 256 glaube ich.
Ah, ah ja stimmt. Hier 2018, da hängt das. 26. Mai 2018, das war ein Tag.
Stimmt, da hatten wir ja richtige Premium-Positionierung.
War kurz davor oder so, auf jeden Fall war der Jan Philipp Eilrich bei uns.
Genau, das ist fünf Jahre her.
Unglaublich. Ja, also auf eine Weise hätte ich gedacht, dass das jetzt schon fünf Jahre her ist.
Ja, es ist fünf Jahre her, wir brauchen auch gar nicht, also das steht ja sogar da.
Das kriegen wir jetzt nicht wegdiskutiert.
Und jetzt, ich würde mich auf die Zusammenfassung von Alexander Fanta und Ingo
Dachwitz bei Netzpolitik.org
beziehen, die nicht einfach mal gesagt haben, nach fünf Jahren,
die fünf größten Stärken der DSGVO und die fünf größten Schwächen,
bevor wir uns deren Interpretation nähern, was würdest du denn sagen Tim?
DSGVO, was hat die DSGVO hier für uns getan?
Also sie hat auf jeden Fall ein Bewusstsein geschaffen dafür,
dass es nicht immer nur darum geht, was Unternehmen so tun können,
sondern dass bei den ganzen Transaktionen im Internet es eben auch eine Nutzerseite
gibt und die haben auch Wünsche.
Und das ist glaube ich erstmal so primär das wichtigste daran,
dass es da ist und dass es überhaupt erstmal Datenschutz auf die Agenda gelegt hat.
Ich find natürlich, es ist ein bisschen spät gekommen. Hätten wir das früher
gehabt, hätte es viele Zentralisierungen und Geschäftsmodelle noch verhindern
können oder verändern können in ihren negativen Auswirkungen.
Finde die DSGVO ist schon ein Beispiel von hinterher reguliert,
ob man es jetzt positiv oder negativ sieht, aber auf jeden Fall hat hier die
Politik sehr viel erst mal geschehen lassen, bis sie eingegriffen hat.
Jetzt finde ich aber gleichzeitig, und damit waren aber auch schon Dinge wiederum zementiert.
Gleichermaßen habe ich aber, wenn man jetzt das nur am Rande,
es wird ja auch der AI-Act diskutiert,
den wir in der nächsten Sendung mal besprechen, wo man natürlich auch sich überlegen
muss, dass potenziell zu früher ein Griff auch echt ein Standortnachteil sein kann.
Jetzt haben wir leider bei der DSGVO die Situation, wir haben jetzt...
Wir haben den Standortnachteil und die späte Regulierung. Da haben wir irgendwie
von beiden das schlechte.
Aber schauen wir mal, was Alexander und Ingo benennen.
Erstens, ein eingelöstes Versprechen, höhere Bußgelder. Wir haben ja jetzt kürzlich,
FaceMeta wurde jetzt irgendwie für 1,2 Milliarden. Strafe müssen die bezahlen.
Also Strafen bei Datenschutzverstößen passieren.
Insgesamt in den vergangenen fünf Jahren rund 2,8 Milliarden Euro an Bußgeldern.
1,2 Milliarden Meter für illegale Verarbeitung von EU-Daten in den USA.
Bis dahin war die höchste Strafe 750 Millionen Euro gegen Amazon.
Also es gibt Strafen und diese Strafen haben natürlich einen oder es gibt Bußgelder
und diese Bußgelder haben natürlich einen wichtigen Punkt.
Nämlich dass das Verletzen von Datenschutzrechten der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
überhaupt monetär spürbar schmerzhaft wird. Ja, das was sonst nicht der Fall
war, deswegen wurden eben auch diese Rechte die ganze Zeit verletzt.
Dann sagen sie zweitens, das Recht auf Datenauskunft, ein wirksames Werkzeug,
da habe ich eigentlich mich gewundert, weil naja so wirklich viel Gebrauch machen
Leute davon nicht und ich habe auch nicht den Eindruck, dass es viel macht.
Entsprechend kommen sie auch zum Schluss, sein Potenzial hat das Recht aber
auch nach fünf Jahren noch nicht voll entfaltet. Oft versuchen Unternehmen die
Anfragen dann mit oberflächlichen Auskämpften abzuspeisen. Erst Anfang Mai.
Hat der entschied der europäische Gerichtsruf nach einer Klage der NGO none
of your business. Max Schrems kennen wir.
Das Betroffene auf Anfrage eine originalgetreue und verständliche Reproduktion
all ihrer Daten erhalten müssen.
Wir erinnern uns an Max der irgendwie
anfangs seine Facebook Daten da irgendwie als PDF bekommen hatte.
Das betrifft nicht nur Rohdaten aus Datenbanken, sondern auch den Kontext in
dem die Daten gespeichert und verarbeitet werden.
Also, schönes Recht, wirksames Werkzeug, frage ich mich wie sie zu dem Schluss
kommen, weil die Frage ist, was wäre denn die Wirkung dieses Werkzeugs,
ne? Also was kannst du denn machen?
Und da sehe ich irgendwie noch nicht so, also sehe ich noch nicht gegeben,
dass das zu einer gesellschaftlichen Veränderung führt, außer dass ein paar
Nerds dieses interessiert sich die Daten geben lassen können, ne?
Drittens, die Macht der vielen. Stark dank der Zivilgesellschaft.
Und da geht es um den Punkt, dass Organisationen,
wie jetzt beispielsweise NGO, deshalb ist es wichtig, dass NGOs,
wie zum Beispiel None of your Business, konkrete Beschwerden einreichen und
Verfahren führen können.
Also dass sie das können ist ein Teil der DSGVO,
war vorher gar nicht unbedingt möglich und da kann man auf jeden Fall sagen,
wenn wir jetzt gerade auf None of your Business gucken, die machen da konsequente
Arbeit an diesem einen Gesetz, reichen Beschwerden ein und.
Arbeiten daran, dass dieses Gesetz auch umgesetzt wird. Sicherlich auch ein positiver Effekt.
Dann finde ich es, gut, ein wichtiger Nebeneffekt mehr IT-Sicherheit.
Oha, also das habe ich bisher noch nicht so mitbekommen, aber nein,
stimmt natürlich, ne. Aufgrund der strengen Regelungen ist auch die Anzahl der
verhängten Bußgelder relativ hoch.
Also wenn du einen IT-Sicherheitsvorfall hast und da sind personenbezogene Daten
dabei, dann kannst du theoretisch Strafen bekommen.
Üblicherweise sehe ich das nicht so häufig. Also es müsste schon wirklich fahrlässig
gewesen sein, die personenbezogene Daten nicht vor unbefugten Zugriffen geschützt
haben. Oder durch das Leak kommt raus, dass du mit den Daten ohnehin falsch umgegangen bist.
Und das finde ich aber auch sehr schön, das große Versprechen den Überwachungskapitalismus
zu bändigen hat die DSGVO jedoch bis heute nicht eingelöst.
Und da sagen sie, das liegt an den größten Flops. Hier sind die größten Flops.
Erstens ein unerwartetes Problem, die Träger der Aufsichtsbehörden.
Dieses 1,2 Milliarden Euro Bußgeld an Meta,
das ist glaube ich ein Verfahren, was um die 10 Jahre gedauert hat,
bis da irgendwann mal, oder nee kann ja gar nicht sein, 10 Jahre kann ja nicht
sein, DSGVO, er ist 5 Jahre alt, also auf jeden Fall viele Jahre gedauert hat,
bis es dann endlich mal die Strafe gab.
Zweitens, ein unerwünschtes Nadelöhr, das Irland-Problem, denn es ist ja so,
dass die meisten Datenschutzkritischen Unternehmen, Facebook,
Microsoft, Google, TikTok, haben ihren Standort in Irland.
Wegen der niedrigen Steuern, aber auch, weil die irische Datenschutzbehörde
eine sehr milde Interpretation der DSGVO hat.
Das hat natürlich entsprechende Nachteile. Ein schwerwiegender Konstruktionsfehler.
Immer wieder Ärger mit der Einwilligung.
Ja, und das ist ja, das muss man auch wirklich sagen.
Datenschutz und DSGVO bleiben ein Buhmann und sind einfach zu diskreditieren.
Weil es eben immer diese Einwilligungsdinger gibt, da kann man irgendwie so
ein Hütchenspiel machen. Sie müssen mal hier was machen wegen Datenschutz.
Denkt jeder so, oh fuck, schon wieder, ja komm hier, klick.
Super Phishing Ding und so weiter. Diese ganze Einwilligungsgeschichte würde
ich sagen funktioniert halt einfach nicht.
Also sie funktioniert schon im Einzelfall kaum und sie skaliert halt überhaupt nicht.
Und das waren ja diese Diskussionen, informt, consent und so weiter,
dass dann immer dir alles mögliche gesagt werden muss und das wo du gerade okay
klickst, das musst du auch verstanden haben und das haben die natürlich.
Und es führt in zunehmendem Maße auch dazu mit entweder Werbung und alles oder
gar nichts, weißt du? Das ist ja auch so eine Konsequenz.
Also genau und diese ganzen Dark Patterns und was da sich nicht alles ergibt.
Also vor allem trainieren wir Menschen diese Dinger wegzuklicken.
Da kannst du natürlich auch alles mögliche nochmal mitmachen.
Also das ist sicherlich ähm...
Nicht so gelungen. Dann fehlende Standards.
Da sieht man natürlich, dass das DSGVO Compliance,
also überall wo es komplizierte Zusammenhänge zu klären gibt für so ein Unternehmen,
entstehen natürlich dann so Compliance Berater.
Die dann irgendwie Datenschutzberater, die dann irgendwie sagen,
das musst du so machen, das musst du so machen.
Überall sagt dann jeder, ja hier wir sind, wir werben damit,
dass wir DSGVO-compliant sind. Wo du sagst so, geil, an welches Gesetz haltet
ihr euch denn noch? Wollt ihr noch weitere? Gibt's noch weitere Gesetze,
die ihr euch rühmt einzuhalten?
Also das hat irgendwie nicht so schön, also nicht so wirklich schön funktioniert.
Dann sagen sie, eine große Leerstelle künstlicher Intelligenz und das Verbot
automatisierter Entscheidungen. Das kommt natürlich jetzt der Punkt.
Ich hatte ja gerade schon gesagt, AI und KI als Regulationsziel kommen.
Ingo und Alexander schreiben, als die Datenschutzgrundverordnung Mitte der 2010er
Jahre geschmiedet wurde, hatte der Begriff Big Data Konjunktur.
Heute werden ähnliche Debatten unter dem Stichwort Künstliche Intelligenz, KI geführt.
Damals geht es wie heute um Diskriminierung, Manipulation und den Schutz vor
allwissenden Maschinen, die über unsere Lebenschancen entscheiden.
Ein wirksamen Schutz gegen die Macht der Algorithmen bietet die GSGVO trotzdem nicht.
Schade für uns, aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht, dass wir dann jetzt
nochmal uns das anschauen können.
So viel zur Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Also interessanterweise,
wie so oft, also was wurde das heiß diskutiert.
Da kann man auch nochmal, wie heißt nochmal der Film mit Jan Philipp Albrecht
und Ralf Bendrath, Democracy, die Braustätigkeit der Daten.
Müssen wir auch nochmal verlinken, der war doch jetzt irgendwie frei geworden, oder?
Ja, mir war so. Bin mir grad nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaub der wurde bei der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung irgendwie
online gelegt oder sowas.
Ja, BPB.
Verlinken. Was für ein Zeitdokument.
Wirklich stark. Man könnte sagen, DSGVO alles nicht ganz so heiß gegessen wie
es gekocht wurde, in beide Richtungen.
Perfekt zusammengefasst. Ja ja, immerhin gibt's hier noch. Was ist eigentlich
mit dem D-E-Mail passiert?
Da war doch auch mal was.
Da war auch mal was. War das 30C3?
Das ist ne gute Frage, dein Vortrag ne?
Ja, Bullshit made in Germany. ähm... Kugel.
2013 vor zehn Jahren ja.
Guck an, geht alles so sauber auf.
Heute nur Fünfer.
Ja wir haben, also D-Mail, das war ein Verfahren,
oder ist ein E-Mail Verkehrsverfahren, das unter besonderen,
angeblich besonderen Sicherheitsbedingungen funktionieren sollte und damit rechtssicheren.
Datenverkehr ermöglichen sollte. Ich habe darüber beim 30C3 einen Vortrag gehalten,
der relativ häufig angeschaut wurde und auf den ich häufig angesprochen werde,
in dem ich dieses System ein bisschen auseinander genommen habe und darüber
gewitzelt habe, was das eigentlich für eine Luftnummer ist.
Und es ist halt einfach eine gewesen, genauso wie der E-Post Brief,
der ist relativ, der ist sehr viel früher.
Im Prinzip eingestampft worden.
Und tja, jetzt hat der Markus Richter, der es irgendwie geschafft hat,
dass seine Berufsbezeichnung CIO Bund ist. Also der bezeichnet sich als der
Chief Information Officer der Bundesregierung.
Und er sagt, dass am 31.8.24,
die D-Mail in der Verwaltung endet. Also die Verwaltung wird nicht mehr über
D-Mail erreichbar sein.
Das trifft jetzt alle so, ooooh. Hahaha. Also...
Leider ist das Bittere, dass er dann sagt, bitte jetzt auf Alternativen umstellen,
vor allem Bund-ID, EGVP oder Unternehmenskonto. EGVP?
Was ist das denn?
Elektronische Gerichtsverkehrspostfach oder sowas. Das ist dieses...
Ach das ist hier unser Freund.
Elektronisches Gerichts- und Verwaltungspostfach.
Das besondere.
Ja das ist, ne ne, besondere elektronische Anwaltspass war nochmal was anderes.
Du sollst das vielleicht auch umbenennen in DBNP, der besondere Netzpolitik Podcast.
Es ist, also das traurige ist,
also die, einige haben mich natürlich dann irgendwie auf Mastodon oder Twitter auch getaggt,
also Linus hier später genug tun, das System wird endlich eingestellt,
also das ist ja so ein ganz langsames Siegtum,
das deutsche Telekom hat ja glaube ich auch schon gesagt, wir machen kein D-Mail
mehr, 1&1 stellt sich allerdings wohl auf die Hinterbeine und sagt,
nein Wahnsinn, kannst du doch nicht, Was kommt als nächstes?
Wollt ihr uns die Faxgeräte mitnehmen?
Jan Oetjen, CEO von Gmx und Web.de kritisierte gegenüber CT die Entscheidung der Bundesregierung.
DML bleibt der einzige interoperable und verfügbare Standard für rechtsverbindliche
digitale Kommunikation in Deutschland, den wir weiter anbieten.
Statt immer wieder neue isolierte Konzepte vorzustellen, sollte man die bestehenden
umsetzen und in Interoperabilität denken.
Sonst falle Deutschland in der Digitalisierung immer weiter zurück.
Deutschland, das Gute ist, Deutschland kann in der Digitalisierung gar nicht
weiter zurückfallen, weil wir sind ja eh schon auf dem letzten Platz.
Vielleicht, also wenn wir Glück haben, steigen wir ab, kommen wir nochmal in eine Relegation.
Ja, zweite Liga.
Ja, das, also...
Ja, zweite Liga sind wir eh schon. Also Deutschland ist eher auf dem Weg in die Regionaldiga.
Ja, also das Bittere ist, also natürlich ist es auf eine Weise lustig zu sehen,
dass ein System, wo man vor zehn Jahren gesagt hat, Du, das wird so nix.
Dass das 10 Jahre dann später auch wirklich sich bewahrheitet, dass das nix wird.
Andererseits ist es halt traurig zu sehen, dass es jetzt auch keine sinnvollen
Alternativen, die in der Zwischenzeit entwickelt wurden, gibt.
Also dieses Bund-ID müssen wir uns vielleicht nochmal genauer anschauen,
aber scheint mir jetzt auch nicht der große Wurf zu sein.
Also alles in allem eine...
Zu Bund-ID gibt es noch nicht mal eine Wikipedia-Seite.
Das war das, was man brauchte, um diese Studentenhilfen da zu bekommen.
Wofür haben die Studenten nochmal Geld bekommen?
Für Heizungszuschuss wegen Russland und so.
Konto erstellen, machen wir eine Bunde-ID. Online-Ausweis. Ach,
das war das mit dem ELSTER-Zertifikat.
Ja, nee, mach ich auch nicht mit.
Könnte er auch versuchen, ohne mich zu machen. Gut, also Ende der DML.
Schön, wäre super, wenn wir jetzt was besseres hätten, aber...
Haben wir nicht. Haben wir nicht.
So, okay.
Ein Thema, was nach wie vor die Gesellschaft bewegt, behindert,
künstliche Intelligenz.
Wir haben da jetzt öfter drüber gesprochen,
aber was ja jetzt als Statement kam,
also sie werden ja immer absurder, jetzt haben hunderte Expertinnen und Experten
mit einem Satz quasi ein Open Letter, Open Statement oder sowas.
Darunter ist Sam Altman, der von OpenAI, der Chef von Google DeepMind,
Jeffrey Hinton und Joshua Bengio, die mit dem Turing Award ausgezeichnet wurden und so weiter.
Und das Statement lautet, es sollte global priorisiert werden,
das Risiko der Auslöschung durch KI zu verringern auf einer Stufe mit anderen
Risiken für die gesamte Gesellschaft, wie etwa Pandemien und Nuklearkrieg.
Also ich mein, okay, spannend, aber wenn du Sam Altman bist und jetzt irgendwie
der Rockstar der Bits bist und irgendwie so sagst,
passt auf, meine Technologie, die wird die Menschheit zerstören,
da passen irgendwie die Dinge nicht zusammen.
Also ich glaube, mir scheinen diese Warnungen gewissermaßen auch ein bisschen Marketing zu sein.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich mein, Joffrey Hinton wird ja mit den entscheidenden
Durchbrüchen im Bereich des Deep Learning verbunden und hat jetzt jahrelang
bei Google gearbeitet, nachdem er sozusagen.
Nach seinem ersten erfolgreichen Deep Learning Paper und sein Veröffentlichung
von Google angestellt wurde und dann ja quasi dort lange Zeit gearbeitet hat
und so ein bisschen so jetzt Godfather auf Deep Learning ist,
der hat jetzt Google verlassen und schlägt jetzt halt andere Töne an.
Weil er eben so das Gefühl hat, dass so ein bisschen Zauberlehrling mäßig,
so jetzt hab ich hier was geschaffen und der Besen der Geht jetzt hier von alleine
und jetzt habe ich ihn aber nicht mehr unter Kontrolle.
Und das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen die Befürchtung,
die diese Szene hat, weil sie halt einfach gemerkt haben,
dass aus ihrem relativ einfachen Ansatz, der es ja nach wie vor ist,
dieses neuronale Netzwerk so zu aktivieren durch tiefe Lernstufen,
dass es eben in der Lage ist, sich wirklich sehr gut trainieren zu lassen und
dann eben mit diesen Large Language Models,
Wo man einfach mal gesagt hat, na was würde denn jetzt mal passieren,
wenn wir dann den ganzen Text der Menschheit drauf kippen,
können wir da irgendwas bei rausfinden und siehe da,
auf einmal können die Dinger problemlos von jeder Sprache in jede Sprache übersetzen,
auf einmal sind sie in der Lage das Internet auf eine Art und Weise zusammenzufassen,
einfach nur durch so eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsvorhersage, die es ja letzten Endes
technisch betrachtet ist, dass da eben sehr sehr sehr sinnvolle Sachen bei rauskommen
und wir sind natürlich jetzt schwer beeindruckt davon,
Aber das hat auch einfach damit zu tun, dass man sich einfach mal klar machen
muss, unsere glorifizierte menschliche Intelligenz, die ist ja so toll jetzt auch nicht.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit unterwhelmt.
Von dir jetzt oder von den anderen? Nein! Von euren.
Naja also klar wir tendieren ja dazu uns total toll zu halten,
so war auch in gewisser Hinsicht manche von uns zumindest aber Menschheit als
solches, Wir haben natürlich den Tieren so viel voraus, dass wir in der Lage
sind, ihnen das Leben sehr schwer zu machen.
Und darauf wählen wir uns halt was ein, aber so richtig geil im Verstehen komplexer
Materie sind dann die meisten halt nicht. Wir haben so ein paar Wunderkinder
und so, die schreiben dann geile Papiere zusammen.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen findet das ja auch nur für ein paar Jahre unseres
Lebens statt so und danach lässt es dann auch schon wieder stark nach.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, diese künstliche Intelligenz tut etwas,
wo sich mal wieder zeigt, dass der Computer das dann besser kann,
weil er das einfach beständiger durchführen kann.
So war es am Anfang mit Rechnen und dann eben mit vielen anderen Tasks,
von denen wir so in den letzten Jahrzehnten profitiert haben und jetzt ist halt
auch dieses Durchwälzen von Text und sinnvolles Zusammenfassen von Text ist
jetzt auch eine Aufgabe,
wo wir herausgefunden haben, wie wir die Computer dahin bringen können,
das eben sehr viel besser zu tun, als wir das können, vor allem sehr viel schneller.
Und deswegen sind wir jetzt so total beeindruckt und immer wenn Menschen total
beeindruckt von irgendwas sind, tendieren wir auch dazu das zu überschätzen
und da liegt sicherlich auch eine Gefahr da drin.
Diese Einschätzung jetzt hingeht.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass die sagen, tut uns leid, ihr überschätzt unser Produkt.
Das ist nicht das, was ich von Sam Altman höre.
Doch insofern nicht das Produkt, sondern die Technologie insofern,
als dass, wenn man sie anwendet, das dann auf andere Leute Auswirkungen hat.
Also ich kann ja jetzt einfach irgendwas schreiben lassen und es wirkt einfach echt.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so einen russischen Propagandasender produzieren möchte,
dann ist das mit diesen Tools relativ einfach.
Ich bin ein Propagandasender, ich möchte gerne die Massen sozusagen hinter eine
falsche Information bringen.
Generiere mir fünf Artikel, die sozusagen diese Thesen hier unterstreichen.
Plopp plopp plopp, weißt du jetzt nicht welche Filter da gerade in ChatGPT vielleicht
noch aktiv sind, um das dann irgendwie zu verhindern, dass er dann kommt mit
so, mhm ach weißt du so Politik äußere ich mich lieber nicht,
kann ja sein, aber wir wissen auch so mit dem richtigen Prompt-Engineering kommt
man da schon drum herum, also du kriegst solche Texte halt generiert.
Und man sieht es ja jetzt schon, die Werbeindustrie springt drauf an.
Es gibt jetzt Unternehmen, die einfach mit dieser Technologie quasi Werbetexte
auf den einzelnen Betrachter hin optimieren.
Wir hatten das schon im Wahlkampf und bei der Brexit-Abstimmung hier mit Cambridge Analytica.
Das war dein Name, ne? Wo ja dann quasi schon diese Facebook Profile benutzt wurden,
um dann eben klar zu targeten, du bist sowieso schon so ein Right Winger,
dir stellen wir mal dieses Doomsday Szenario bei und du bist aber eigentlich
so ein Left Winger, dir zeigen wir mal irgendwas, was sich davon abhält,
Hillary Clinton zu wählen.
Und diese Methodik, die kann natürlich jetzt noch sehr viel mehr verfeinert
werden und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das, wo Sie da die Gefahren drin
sehen, weil Sie sehen, diese Werkzeuge werden jetzt sehr schnell in die Hände
von sehr vielen Leuten kommen.
Und es ist auch absehbar, dass die nächste Generation von Large Language Models,
die ja bedeutet schneller, höher, weiter, durch mehr entsteht hier mehr.
Also die Unterschiede von GPT 2, 3, 4 sind zwar auch teilweise technischer Natur,
aber haben vor allem damit zu tun, dass eben sehr viel mehr an Material reingeballert
wurde und mehr Ressourcen zur Verfügung gestellt wurden.
Durch noch mehr Bereitstellung dieser Ressourcen und noch mehr Analyse von Tags ist es schon absehbar,
dass eben noch sehr viel mehr Finesse in diese Sache reinkommt,
wo man heute sich immer wieder so die Schenkel klopft mit so,
guck mal hier, was Chet Chibiti wieder für einen Scheiß erzählt.
Ja also in der nächsten Version wird das dann schon wieder noch filigraner formuliert
sein und dann wird's langsam schwierig das irgendwie noch zu unterscheiden von Wahrheit.
Also wir haben den ganzen Wahrheitsbereich, wir haben Ethik und Verantwortung,
Verantwortung für Verhandlungen, autonomer System oder Entscheidungen.
Wir haben insgesamt natürlich auch Missbrauch, also seltsam.
Wenn Leute demnächst alles machen, was der Computer sagt, dann ist das natürlich
auch ein interessantes Angriffsziel.
Arbeitsplatzverlust, das ist natürlich echt ein Thema. Also ich hätte den Satz
vielleicht ein bisschen anders umformuliert.
Es ist schon ganz gut möglich, dass es ein paar Jobs demnächst nicht mehr gibt
und die auch nicht ersetzt werden, außer durch hier werde KI-Lehrer und klicke
irgendwie unerwünschtes Output.
Da kommen sicherlich gesellschaftliche Umwerfungen und Veränderungen auf uns zu,
aber die liegen auch, kannst du weniger jetzt die Technologie für verantwortlich machen,
dann aber dieses, was ja alle denken,
also wenn du jetzt Lieschen Müller auf der Straße fragst und sagst,
wie wird KI Wortbestand der Menschheit, was ist die Gefahr, dann sagst du,
ja, die KI, die ist klüger als wir, die macht uns alle fertig,
gerät außer Kontrolle und richtet sich gegen uns.
Gegen ihren Schöpfer. Gab's ja auch diese Nachricht, dass in irgendeiner Simulation
jetzt eine Drohne am Ende ihren Operator abknallen wollte. Das war aber fake.
Ja genau. Das gab's nicht. Natürlich nicht.
Also guckst du dir an und sagst so nein. Nein. Noch nicht. Noch zu früh.
Die Frage ist, welche dieser Gefahren manifestieren sich wirklich?
Und die beste Interpretation, die ich da jetzt gerade habe ist,
also auf jeden Fall wird das, wie alle anderen technischen Innovationen glaube
ich auch, so diesem Gardner-Hype-Cycle folgen.
Kennst du den, Janosch? Also eine Kurve, die einen Technology Trigger hat,
dann geht es zum Peak der aufgeblasenen Erwartungen,
dann durch das Tal der Desillusion, dann kommt der Aufstieg des Enlightenment,
der Erleuchtung und dann ein Plateau der Produktivität.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das, also in diesem System ist auf jeden Fall ein massiver...
Effizienz, Produktivität, Nutzungszuwachs drin. Und die Frage ist natürlich
immer wo bist du gerade auf diesem Hype-Cycle.
Wahrscheinlich bist du irgendwo zwischen Technology Trigger und Peak of Inflated Expectations.
Aber du weißt halt noch nicht genau wo. Also ich würde vermuten,
wahrscheinlich sind wir noch hier.
Ganz am Anfang mit hier.
Noch sehr am Anfang.
Ja kommt drauf an, also ich meine wenn man Machine Learning und Deep Learning
jetzt in den letzten 20 Jahren mal zusammenpackt, denke ich mal sind wir jetzt
schon eher auf dem Pfad der Erleuchtung.
Das ist nämlich das, genau, das ist genau die Frage und da wollte ich auch ein
bisschen drauf aus, ich habe mit einem Kollegen einen Vortrag gehalten und werde
den auch noch ein paar mal halten bei der Heise Security Tour.
Über im Prinzip wie diese sogenannte KI die die IT-Sicherheit verändern wird.
Und Janis mit dem ich den Vortrag halte, der hat diesen Kram studiert.
Also der auch glaub ich promoviert in diesem Bereich.
Im Bereich der angewandten Mathematik mit eben Deep Learning.
Und schon sehr interessant, wir haben in früheren Sendungen auch darüber gesprochen,
wie funktioniert das genau, was wird da überhaupt gemacht, ja?
Können wir eigentlich hier in der Sendung auch nochmal besser erklären,
als was wir bisher getan haben.
Und er hat da tatsächlich, glaube ich, einen relativ informierten Blick drauf,
wo auch die Grenzen dieser Systeme sind.
Also Unmengen an Potentialen, aber eben auch Grenzen.
Und sagt so aktuell würde er eher sagen, das ist so ein Buzzword,
jetzt muss alles KI haben, das System komplexer aussehen zu lassen als es ist,
ist natürlich im Interesse der Hersteller, dann gibt's einen Bias,
wir sehen immer nur die beeindruckenden guten Beispiele auf Twitter und extrapolieren
davon, oh wenn es das kann, dann kann es auch das.
Und natürlich, es kann sprechen, also muss es intelligent sein.
Was uns auf jeden Fall zu einer Art der Überschätzung führen wird.
Was aber in diesem Vortrag entscheidend, der entscheidende Perspektive ist,
ist Machine Learning ist nur bei bestimmten Problemen überlegen.
Nämlich, du hast da, also Machine Learning heißt ja eigentlich,
du hast Daten und extrahierst die Regeln, die sich da drin befinden.
Also du hast Input, Output und extrahierst Regeln. Mit Algorithmen hast du Input
und Regeln und generierst Output und bei Machine Learning generierst du aus
Input und Output die Regeln, die du dann auf neues Input anwendest.
Und diese Regeln, die das Ding lernt, sind komplett implizit und nicht kontrollierbar.
Teilweise auch explizit. Jedenfalls, du brauchst also Daten,
die eindeutig sind und die du in großer Menge hast, um das Modell irgendwie lernen zu lassen.
Du brauchst eine Komplexität, wo die Zusammenhänge nicht offensichtlich sind
und sich nicht mit einfachen Regeln sofort abbilden lassen, weil dann brauchst
du eigentlich kein Machine Learning.
Das heißt, viele Daten, komplexe Zusammenhänge da drin und irgendeine Form von Evaluierbarkeit.
Du musst quasi, um dem Ding was beibringen zu können, vergleichen können,
wenn es zwei Wege gibt oder zwei Lösungswege, zwei Modelle, welcher von beiden
der bessere ist. Also brauchst du eine loss function, auf die du optimieren kannst.
Wenn du diese drei Dinge hast, dann hast du ein Problem, bei dem Machine Learning
potenziell überlegen ist.
Mit dem Framework nähern wir uns dann eben so unterschiedlichen Bereichen und sagen,
werden die jetzt in technischer IT-Sicherheit, werden die jetzt von Machine
Learning massiv verbessert oder vielleicht sogar ein Problem gelöst,
was wir vorher nicht lösen konnten oder nicht.
War ganz interessant die Zusammenarbeit.
Hat den Vorteil, es geht nicht um die Gesellschaft, es geht nur um IT-Security,
kennen wir uns ein bisschen mit aus.
Und natürlich bin ich da und muss sagen, nein, nein, nein, mein Job ist sicher.
Ich bin ein guter Hacker, das was ich hier kann, das kann noch niemals dieses Jett-GPT.
Es ist ein Feld, wo ich glaube,
dass genau diese Art von Untersuchungen und Überlegungen in spezifischen Feldern,
ja, also wie wird das jetzt durch Machine Learning revolutioniert werden können oder nicht,
das sind die Fragen, die wir uns noch sehr viel mehr stellen müssen und nicht
erstmal davon ausgehen, ah geil, es kann sprechen, also wird es alles ersetzen, was sprechen kann.
Ich glaube auf jeden Fall wird es die Searchbar ersetzen, so für alles,
man wird nicht mehr googeln, man wird einfach die Frage stellen.
Genau, das mach ich jetzt schon. Also ich hab's googeln weitgehend eingestellt,
wenn es um das Beantworten von wirklichen Fragestellungen geht.
Nur wenn ich halt auf der Suche nach Webseiten bin, dann benutze ich halt die Suchmaschine.
Und die Ergebnisse sind ziemlich gut muss ich sagen.
Also fast immer führt mich die erste Frage zur Lösung. Das finde ich schon ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Muss man natürlich ein bisschen lernen wie man fragt so, aber ich glaube man
kriegt da relativ schnell ein Gefühl dafür und das ist alles sehr praktisch.
Also ich bin insofern auch sehr angetan von dem ganzen, weil es halt wirklich
eine praktische Auswirkung hat.
Aber die Granularität, du hast ja gerade gesagt, mit dieser loss function,
also was da sozusagen mit drinsteckt,
ist die Bewertung von Wahrheit eigentlich in dem was man da macht.
Also was ist für mich wirklich relevant, was ist nicht relevant.
Trainiere ich jetzt irgendwie Bilder von Blumen und ich will da auf bestimmte
Blumen hinaus, dann muss ich ja irgendwo auch die Informationen haben.
Welche Blume das ist. Ist das jetzt hier wirklich auch eine Sonnenblume oder
denkst du das jetzt nur, indem man das halt in diesen Daten annotiert,
hierbei handelt es sich jetzt tatsächlich
um das, kann ja dieses Wissen so überhaupt erst erzeugt werden.
Allerdings sind halt diese Large Language Models und eben einfach durch dieses
hinzufügen von soviel Ressourcen zeigt sich auch,
dass das trainieren dieser neuronalen Netzwerke halt wirklich in der Lage ist
eine inhärente Struktur in Dingen zu entdecken, wo wir bisher auch noch nicht
mal auch nur einen Ansatz haben irgendwas zu finden.
Ja, also für so Sachen wie, ich gab ja hier schon früher diese Sachen mit,
wir filtern jetzt mal das Rauschen aus dem All und suchen mal nach irgendwie
intelligentem Leben und so, wo bis heute nix gefunden wurde,
das kann durchaus nochmal einen neuen Ansatz bekommen.
Oder du hast irgendwelche alten Binärformate,
irgendwelche Dateien aus den 80er Jahren, wo es die Software nicht mehr dafür gibt,
dann ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass so ein System in der Lage ist,
diese inhärente Struktur einfach aus sich heraus zu erkennen und dir Vorschläge
zu machen und dann natürlich die Möglichkeit all diese ganzen Dinge miteinander
kombinieren zu können, wie wir das ja heute schon sehen.
Fütter Chat.GPT mit einer Idee für ein Theaterstück und am besten auch noch
gleich mit einer kompletten Bühnenbildbeschreibung und dann kommt was dabei
raus und dann nimmst du diese Bühnenbildbeschreibung,
schmeißt sie in deinen Midjourney rein, dann kriegst du halt auch gleich die Optik.
So, dann kannst du diese Optik wieder in ein anderes Ding machen,
dann kriegst du deine 3D-Modelle da draus und dann kannst du das irgendwie direkt
in die CNC-Fräse schmeißen und dann wird das auch gebaut.
Sowas werden wir sehen und das ist natürlich eine totale Revolution in der Automatisierung
von allem möglichen Scheiß. Also das ist wirklich auch interessant. Ich kenne fast kaum...
Jemanden, der in irgendeiner Form jetzt so aktiv mit mit mit Zeug arbeitet also
im Sinne von Computer basiert an irgendetwas arbeitet,
wo nicht schon irgendwie zumindest drüber nachgedacht wird oder rumprobiert wird,
so etwas zum Einsatz zu bringen egal ob es irgendwie Gamer sind,
Programmierer auf allen Fronten, Jeder Programmierer hat mal seinen eigenen
Code reingeschmissen und gerade was so IT Security betrifft.
Einfach mal solche Modelle auf deinen eigenen Code anwenden und fragen,
ist hier irgendeine Sicherheitslücke drin?
So da kriegst du interessante Antworten. Das gilt natürlich für Verteidiger
genauso wie für Angreifer.
Das ist in diesem Vortrag so ein bisschen der entscheidende Faktor,
dass wir versuchen zu überlegen, es gibt das Angriffsproblem,
es gibt das Verteidigungsproblem und findet sich eventuell in der Beschaffenheit
der Situation ein Unterschied,
der der Verteidigung oder dem Angriff einen vielleicht kurzfristigen oder auch
einen langfristigen Vorteil verschafft bei der Verwendung.
Solcher Systeme. Da werden wir sicherlich irgendwann hier in der Sendung nochmal
ausführlicher drüber sprechen.
Ich denke auf jeden Fall, dass es sinnvoll ist sich darüber Gedanken zu machen,
was die wirklich können und auch zu erkennen wo sind die Grenzen,
möglichst da wo die oder wo diese LLMs nicht geeignet sind,
da sollte man wahrscheinlich selber Kompetenzen aufbauen, Wenn man noch einen
Job haben möchte oder wenn man noch irgendwie Beiträge leisten möchte und da
gibt es diesen Tweet, der auch immer wieder rauf und runter scrollt.
Mit dem AI is not going to take your job, somebody using AI will.
Ja das könnte schon so sein und wenn wir alle keinen Job mehr haben,
wäre auch super, dann würden wir die Plackerei endlich los.
Was soll denn das? Ich will aber einen Job.
Hey Leute, seid doch mal vor. Dann könnt ihr auch an der Kreuzung chillen,
wenn einer festgelegt wird.
Da freut man sich, dass man nicht zur Arbeit fährt.
So, wenn wir diese Sendung veröffentlichen, habe ich schon eine Idee,
wie wir neue Hörer erreichen können. Ja, wie? Wir machen einfach einen Cell-Broadcast,
das ist jetzt der neue heiße Scheiß.
Und das ist doch eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, wir sagen einfach hier neues Logbuch Netzpolitik verfügbar.
Bäm Bäm Bäm.
Einfach auf jedes Handy drauf.
Also so 2G, 3G, 4G?
Da muss man bestimmt bei irgendeiner Behörde einen Fax hinschicken und sagen hier wichtig.
Achtung.
Achtung. Warnung für das gesamte Internet. So dann werden so vereinzelte Zellen
in Deutschland aktiviert.
Ganz wichtig. Also immerhin. Wir dürfen das auch benutzen, weil wir haben ja
auch gefordert, dass es eingeführt wird.
Ja, habe ich eigentlich erzählt, habe ich das hier in der Sendung erzählt,
dass ich eine Cell Broadcast Warnung erhalten habe.
Ich glaube das hatten wir alle schon mal hier erwähnt. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Bei der...
Ich glaube wir hatten das. Beim Easterhack. Beim Easterhack hast du auch noch eine bekommen?
Ja.
Das hast du nicht erwähnt.
Beim Easterhack stand ich mit meinem Van auf dem Campingplatz in Hamburg und
hab dann da gecampt, mit dem Auto geschlafen.
Und irgendwann zu Nacht schlafender Zeit mit 6 Uhr oder sowas,
Alarm, und ich bin so reingeguckt und dann stand da irgendwie so,
ja hier Brand in Hamburg, Giftwolke zieht in die Stadt und so und ich so,
ach okay, und dann irgendwie so geguckt, wo ist dieser Brand,
irgendwas, ein groß Baum, ich so, ach großer Baum, das ist oben im Norden oder so.
Das ist weit weg von da, wo ich ja bin. Insofern weiter schlafen passt schon.
Die Wolke, die hat hier nichts zu tun.
So, dann weiter geschlafen,
paar Stunden später, wache ich auf und denke mir so,
ah, okay, machs mal irgendwie so rollhänden runter und sehe erstmal auf der
Dachluke liegt irgendwie alles mögliche Zeug, ne, und ich denke mir so,
was ist denn jetzt los, hat irgendwie was auf mein Auto geregnet.
Ich mach vorne die Windschutzscheibe, den Vorhang auf und seh einfach dieses Feuer.
Und ich war ungefähr 800 Meter von dem Feuer weg, dieses Gebiet,
was da brannte in Hamburg, das war dieser Großbrand zu Ostern,
die haben da über 24 Stunden dran rumgelöscht.
Dieses Gebiet, was da brannte, war einfach mal, da stand ich halt, neben.
Die ganze Karre voll mit Asche, weil halt aus der Wolke, dann halt die Asche,
irgendwann wird die kalt so nach eben offenbar ein paar hundert Metern,
dann ist die nicht mehr warm genug oder der Auftrieb von der Wolke.
Eine ganze Karre voll mit dem Scheiß, super.
Dann hab ich die irgendwie abgespritzt und bin weggefahren. Also Self-Broadcast.
Wenn man nur drauf hören würde.
Lohnt sich das zu lesen.
Okay, dann können wir das ja auch sein lassen mit der Podcast-Ankündigung,
wenn da eh keiner drauf reagiert.
Der war ja den ganzen Tag noch Theater, weil die da nicht wussten,
was da überhaupt brennt und ein IBC nach dem anderen da explodiert ist mit irgendwelchen
Giften drin und so. War in Ordnung.
Aber du hast gut geschlafen?
Gut geschlafen, leichter Husten seitdem, aber ansonsten, nein,
aber das war wirklich, soll ich dir mal die Bilder zeigen?
Wenn du sie mir zeigst, dann musst du sie auch veröffentlichen, das willst du nicht, ne?
Aber ja, war auf jeden Fall alles heile geblieben,
also das Auto zumindest, ich weiß nicht wie es mir geht, aber ich glaube auch,
meine Hoffnung ist schon, dass diese Wolke halt nach oben gezogen ist und ich
da jetzt kein Gift eingeatmet habe.
Aber also ich wollte damit bestätigen, also ich bin Zeuge, das System gibt es
und es funktioniert und jetzt war am 3.6.
Also vor ein paar Tagen die Meldung, 100 Tage Cell Broadcast in Deutschland,
es wurde bereits 77 mal eingesetzt.
In 100 Tagen.
Inhalte zahlen, ja.
Das ist ganz schön viel. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es über ganz Deutschland
abgeregnet ist, sondern Cell.
Broadcast heißt halt nur in bestimmten Zellen.
Ja und das hätte ich mir auch denken können, als ich die Warnung bekommen habe.
Also funktioniert. Kann ich bestätigen.
Du hättest gerettet werden können.
Warntag. Ja hat aber auch irgendwie keine Sau interessiert, dass wir da in der
Giftwolke gecampt haben.
Also jetzt wo du das sagst, ich hab auch den Zellbroadcast bekommen tatsächlich,
allerdings war ich nicht 800 Meter von der Giftwolke entfernt,
also sie haben die Zellen dann doch schon etwas großräumiger ausgewählt.
Ja klar, vor allem, weil die Wolke ja eben, die zog ja wirklich in Richtung
der Stadt und jetzt ist natürlich,
klar da weiß man dann immer nicht, wenn da jetzt Giftstoffe entstehen,
wie schwer sind die, fallen die vielleicht wieder runter und werden dann da
Bleidampf oder sowas eingegraben?
Wind kann auch drehen und so.
Also haben die ganz Hamburg gewarnt glaube ich. Aber auch der Nachteil,
also das ist wirklich ein Problem an diesen Dingern, also Implementierungsproblem.
Du drückst da drauf und die Warnung ist weg.
Und kommt nicht wieder.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen, da müssen wir nochmal bei Leute,
weil ich muss das ja erstmal in meinen LLM füttern, damit mir das dann erklärt,
wie ich mich verhalten soll.
Genau, woher sollen wir wissen, woran wir sind.
So, da haben wir nochmal einen Job zu verteilen, wir haben ja gerade schon über
Neub gesprochen, als es um die DSGVO ging. None of your business, die NGO von Max Schrems.
Und der doch ist, ich habe recht, es ist ein zehnjähriger Fall gewesen mit der
1,2 Milliarden DSGVO Strafe.
Von 2013 bis 2023 wurde der diskutiert über Metas Beteiligung an der US-Massenüberwachung.
Denn wir haben ja auch zehn Jahre Snowden.
Haben wir ja auch.
Und das ist eben ein Verfahren zwischen Max Schrems und META vor dem,
diesem irischen Datenschutz Ding.
Ja, und nach dem FISA 702,
das ist Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act,
die irische Datenschutzbehörde hat quasi gesagt, da ist nix,
der europäische Datenschutzausschuss hat die Entscheidung der irischen Datenschutzbehörde
weitgehend aufgehoben.
Und verlangte dann außerdem diese Rekordstrafe, sowie eine Rückübertragung bereits
übermittelter Daten in die EU.
Also, None of your Business, NEUB, eine NGO, die da,
würde ich sagen, sehr, wie soll man das sagen,
sehr saubere und nachhaltige Arbeit leistet, darin hier diesen Gesetzen zu Wirkung zu verhelfen.
Und die verlangen, äh die verlangen, die, Neup verlangt,
die klagen jetzt ein, einen Fullstack-Developer, genau die hätten gerne Unterstützung
durch einen ein oder zwei Fullstack-Developer in Ruby on Rails, ja.
Kurzvorstellung, wir konzentrieren uns auf strategische, innovative und effiziente
Anwendung der Privacy-Laws und damit eben auch Verletz- oder Bestrafung von
absichtlichen Privacy-Law-Violations bei den großen Unternehmen.
Mehr als 800 Complaints gegen Big Tech wie Google, Amazon, Meta.
Und entsprechend auch ein Erfolg. So, die suchen Front- und Backend-Developer
für webbasierte Projekte im Legal-Tech-Bereich.
Da geht es sowohl um Projekte, die sie schon haben, die also dann gepflegt werden müssen.
Und interne Tools, um ihre Cases da zu managen.
Natürlich auch automatisierte Detektion von Online-Tracking und Class-Action-Plattforms,
also Sammelklagen-Plattformen.
Ich denke, man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, worum es da geht.
Natürlich in enger Kooperation mit
dem Legal-Team, dass diese Dinge den rechtlichen Rahmen dafür absteckt.
Und diese Software soll natürlich auch geteilt werden und gemeinsam entwickelt
werden mit dem breiteren Consumer Rights and Non-Profit Environment.
Gebeten wird um gutes Verständnis von Ruby und Rails und JavaScript,
Allround-Knowledge in IT, Erfahrungen mit Web-Applikationen,
Front- und Backend, Teamwork, Kommunikation flüssig in der englischen Sprache.
Und ich denke, das könnte durchaus ein interessanter Job sein.
Deswegen haben wir den verlinkt Und wünschen euch viel spaß bei Neub.
Genau ich meine Programmierjob und gleichzeitig ein bisschen Welt retten ist
ja jetzt nicht unbedingt Standard beim Programmieren.
Genau gibt's selten Programmiererjobs bei der auf der guten Seite.
Und da sie hier auch so 20 bis 40 Stunden die Woche Möglichkeit sehen,
Würde ich sowas immer vielleicht so sehen als eine Möglichkeit zu sagen,
ja guck mal, ich würde eigentlich gerne als Freelancerin arbeiten,
ich brauche aber so eine feste Basis mit einer halben Stelle,
in einer guten Umgebung, in einer guten Arbeitsumgebung, die mir zum Beispiel
dabei hilft sicherzustellen, dass Miete und so weiter klar ist und in der restlichen
Zeit mit Freelance-Projekten vielleicht noch ein Euro dazu zu verdienen.
Paar Datenschutzumgehmechanismen coden, die ich mit einem anderen Job dann wieder
einfangen oder so, da kann man ja, kann man sich gleich wieder reinwaschen von seinen Sünden.
Sie sagen aber auch hier, please note, australian employment law requires to
publish a minimum wage, considerably higher salaries are possible depending on qualifications.
Australien? Austrien. Blame Australia. Blame Australia.
Alle sind schuld.
Ja, so sieht es aus. So jetzt nehmen wir ein Fitting und ich nehme mein Fahrrad.
Dann verkloppen wir ein paar Klimakleber.
Die sitzen doch bestimmt schon in ihrem Privatjet.
Ja, hast du dieses orange Privatjet auf Sylt gesehen? Der hat sich,
haben sich nicht so viele drüber aufgeregt.
Orangener Privatjet auf Sylt?
Letzte Generation hat da so ein Jet auf Sylt.
Ach haben die ein bisschen getagged oder was?
Kann man so sagen. Tag ist großes Tag. Ist schön orange geworden.
Schön oranges Flugzeug. Ich hoffe das
geht wieder ab. Naja, ist ja auch sicherheitsrelevant sowas, ne? Also...
Wie jetzt? Sag nicht, das ist jetzt auch nur sicherheitsrelevant!
Die Außenhaut eines Flugzeuges ist natürlich selbstverständlich eine Außenhaut
eines Flugzeugs sicherheitsrelevant.
Das hat ja was mit Strömung und so weiter zu tun.
Wenn es nur fürs Foto ist, okay, wenn es gut abwaschbar ist,
passt ja. Naja, da musst du dir auch über solche Sachen Gedanken machen.
Sonst wird man ja auch zu schnell wieder rausgenommen aus dem Produktionszyklus.
Eine Dachdeckerei auf Sylt ist unzufrieden mit.
Ach, das ist der Privatjet von einer Dachdeckerei?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, vielleicht soll ich Dachdecker werden.
Die sagen sie empfehlen den Leuten, achso das ist, diese Dachdeckerei hat im
Prinzip gesagt geht mal arbeiten, am besten bei uns.
Das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit neue Mitarbeiter zu gewinnen.
Gut Leute wir machen mal hier Ende erstmal für heute und dann sprechen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
So machen wir das.
Ist jetzt Sommer wird ein bisschen schwierig mit Terminen aber wir schaffen das.
Wird schwierig mit Terminen und Themen also Sommerloch kommt.
Was könnten mögliche Themen sein für einen Podcast, erfinde ein paar Vorkennter,
die einem die Gelegenheit geben ein paar Witze zu reißen.
Ja also wir haben noch ein bisschen Snowden thematisch, wir haben Chat Kontrolle,
Logbuch Netzpolitik, der Podcast über Chat GPT und Chat Kontrolle,
da wird es schon noch ein paar Themen geben.
Jaja mach ich mir auch keine Sorgen. Gut ihr seid entlassen bis dann. Ciao.